va démarrer par le sujet stéphane
guillon alors stéphane guillon qui a
beaucoup beaucoup balancé notamment sur
tirer ardisson il était ancien
chroniqueur de salut les terriens sur
ces 8 ils étaient invités que c'est à
vous sur france 5 pour promouvoir un
livre journal d'un infréquentable dans
ce livre il fracasse beaucoup de ses
anciens collègues et dans un instant
avec nous on aura stéphane simon
l'actuel producteur de salut les
terriens et terrien du dimanche qui
était donc le producteur de stéphane
guillon va revenir ensemble sur le
nombre de déclarations qui a fait
stéphane guillon dans son livre et sur
le plateau d' anne elisabeth lemoine
il a notamment raconté que thierry
ardisson pleurer sur commande pour selon
lui l'humaniser pour s'humaniser plutôt
regarder alors par exemple votre patron
donc il a une expression et 10 tourner
ma poule
vous écrivez aujourd'hui c'est ringard
mais personne ne lui dit rien
précisément parce que c'est le panneau 4
ou encore comment votre vous raconter
comment votre patron pleure sur commande
à l'antenne il adore pleurer à l'antenne
sa l'humanise parfois ils pleurent pas
au bon moment alors là qu'est ce qui se
passe sur un canard parfait en couple et
ont refait la séquence pour qu'ils
pleurent exactement là où elle a décidé
de pleurer puisque en conférence de
rédaction décide que thierry pleurs à
tel moment alors dans son livre stéphane
guillon appel ardisson le patron pour
lui éviter tout problème
est ce que vous aimez ou est ce que vous
aimez pas alors je vous racontais
d'autres choses thierry ardisson lui a
répondu un dans son communiqué dans la
journée il est illettré venir stéphane
après son échec au cinéma pluton échec
au théâtre il ne te reste plus que
l'invention de fake news pour exister
médiatiquement en disant tu n'as jamais
participé à aucune conférence de
rédaction de salut les terriens et tu
n'as pas davantage été présent lors des
tournages des témoignages en revanche dû
gagner dix mille euros par semaine et je
comprends qu'aujourd'hui cela te manque
cruellement
mais de là à mentir et à me dénigrer
sans raison et sans preuve
il y a une limite que tu franchis dans
la honte alors est ce que vous aimez ou
est ce que vous n'aimez pas les
déclarations de stéphane guillon petite
pancarte pour donner mathieu vous aimez
non mais il va l'avoir j'aime bien
souvent là au moins au moins se défend -
je n'aime pas du tout la réponse de
thierry ardisson gerra thierry balance
sur tout le monde est ce que pour autant
qu'ils nous expliquent ils gagnent 100
mille deux cent mille euros par mois où
j'en sais rien et doivent aider beaucoup
plus que dix mille euros par semaine
donc ils cliquent lâche tout le monde et
quand on se cache une fois c'est déjà
arrivé notamment avec un auteur n'est
pas longtemps avec beigbeder il fait des
réponses gigantesque pousse tout de
suite il sort des montants il a des
réponses se trouvent pas très net et en
plus on sait tous ce pardon on sait tous
que oui il enregistre en 6 heures
oui il ya des auteurs que oui montrent
tout pour que ce soit en sa faveur en
permanence et jamais pour les inviter
leurs problèmes et carabines non je
n'aime pas la manière de pimenter
l'émission s'appelle vous l'attaquez
d'accord c'est moi en attendant tous les
invités qui sortent dit je viens me
foutrait plus jamais les pieds le
montage ça n'allait pas toujours pas de
vrai ou pas d'ailleurs